and we are the champions was the first
record on there right
it's one of the most like iconic like
underappreciated historical moments in
hip-hop because that was
really when we heard yay before we knew
who the [ __ ] he was
i mean people you know the thing about
that was
it was uh
the reason for is uh what i will say
about kanye is he's the only one
on the real level that's giving me a
certain kind of respect
the only one and it doesn't matter
because he's the biggest one right he's
the only being in the whole crew
it's funny you know
but he's the only one that's paid proper
respect and he's always been that guy
and what happened was i had asked jess
blaze to flip that beat for me and just
blaze did not and i was aggravated about
it like i yelled at him about it
probably because i found it
disrespectful like i send an order and
you [ __ ] don't prioritize it
and i asked kanye to do he did it that
day
that night
and you know history was made and it was
just because of the respect that he gave
me
is the reason why i was so successful
was the record that the first record he
got played on the record on the radio as
a rapper
yeah yeah it can't you know it was
beautiful i mean in fact that was the
first moment we knew it was the first
time queen had actually cleared a sample
they cleared it for me
and i feel like it was the first time we
heard
twista officially repping that rock
yeah
he always considered my brother him and
raw
those are my brothers